keanu reeves hit hollywood like a cool
breeze in the 80s that's what his name
means in hawaiian and ever since he's
been one of cinema's most intriguing and
versatile actors but is his poetry any
good was alice cooper really his
babysitter here's the untold truth of
keanu reeves
when reeves went to the late show in
december 2021 to promote his return as
neo and the matrix resurrections stephen
colbert took upon himself to divert the
conversation a bit and ask him about sad
keanu an immensely popular meme based on
a 2010 picture of bree sullenly eating a
sandwich on a bench reeves explained his
state of mind at the time of the iconic
meal i was thinking i had some stuff
going on sure
i was hungry like any of us reeves was
just trying to fill his stomach and
ponder the complexities of life while
doing so but he inadvertently provided
the internet with one of the most viral
memes of all time back in 2011 when the
meme was still pretty fresh she told bbc
how he really feels about it do i wish
that i didn't get my picture taken and
while i was eating a sandwich on the
streets of new york yeah
living is something that keanu reeves
has been doing for a long time the actor
was born in 1964 but some people on the
internet have come to believe that
reeves is a whole lot older than 57. in
2010 a reddit poster noted that there is
a striking resemblance between reeves
and portraits of paul monae a french
actor who died in the early 20th century
but whose body was never found not long
after the post began drawing attention
someone made a small addition to monet's
wikipedia page writing he currently acts
under the pseudonym of keanu reeves the
source of his eternal youth is not known
the addition went unchanged for several
weeks and reeves immortality conspiracy
was born it didn't take long for the
official keanu reeves immortal website
to enter the scene the site features
pictures of reeves throughout the years
and he does appear to age at about the
same rate as paul rudd in addition to
monet reeves is also confirmed to have
been king charlemagne who lived from
748-814
and crowned his son as king shortly
before dying and undergoing a rushed
winter burial
it's a small world after all keanu
reeves might have played in dog star
through the 90s but his connection to
rock and roll goes back way further than
that in an interview with jimmy fallon
reeves confirmed that alice cooper used
to babysit him as a kid reeves explained
that he grew up in toronto just down the
street from a recording studio called
nimbus 9. reeves mother was a costume
designer who often worked with musicians
and she happened to have a connection
with alice cooper reeves confessed that
he doesn't actually remember spending
any time with the rock legend he said
that's so rad i mean i don't know how
that could actually possibly happen
so but it did supposedly yeah the only
part of the experience that reeves can
recall is a prank that cooper pulled he
recounted i remember that he uh that
there was fake poo
in the fridge of course actors and rock
stars cross paths all the time but it's
not often that their encounters lead to
a story this delightful
everyone has to start somewhere and
keanu reeves got a start in the movie
business partially against his will when
he was still just a teenager reeves
stepfather paul aaron was working on a
second feature film the summer that
reeves turned 15. reeves told the
guardian it was my summer holiday from
school and for parents it's like what do
you do with this kid over the summer i
know we'll make him a production
assistant on a movie a force of one
starring chuck norris wasn't the most
auspicious start to a film career but
the job got reeves invested in the magic
of making movies reeves said i was
watching the grips i was watching actors
i was seeing how a film set really works
he spent weeks learning the ins and outs
of a film set but mostly he fetched
buckets of ice to keep the drinks and
snacks cool still he learned his most
important lesson about filmmaking on
that set he said a movie is all hands on
deck i love all hands on deck that love
has never left reeves and neither has
his work ethic during the production of
john wick 4 reeves blew up online yet
again when someone caught footage of him
lugging heavy equipment around like
another crew member 42 years later
reeves is just as hard working as ever
in one of keanu reeves earliest roles he
plays a hard-working cyclist who powers
through a long race and gets rewarded
with a cool glass bottle of coca-cola
hey i'm proud of you really proud
reeves reminisced about the role on the
late late show with james corden and the
memories brought a wide smile to his
face the three-day commercial shoot was
one of reeves first tastes of being a
working actor and all these years later
he can still enthusiastically recall the
excitement and camaraderie that he felt
on the set with reeves reputation for
being one of the most hardworking actors
in hollywood it will probably surprise
no one that he shaved his legs for the
role there aren't many actors even at
the beginning of their careers who would
go that far for a minute-long coat
commercial
because of his starring roles in major
hollywood blockbusters people often
think of keanu reeves as an american
movie star but that couldn't be further
from the truth if anything reeves was
more of an international man of mystery
reeves was born in lebanon after his
parents english-born patricia and
chinese hawaiian samuel met on a beach
in beirut shortly after reeves birth the
family moved to australia and not long
after that his parents separated
ultimately patricia relocated the family
to new york for a brief stint before
settling in toronto reeves has been a
canadian citizen for most of his life
though his frequent trips to los angeles
and other parts of the world obscure
that fact for most of his fans when he
was asked in an interview why he keeps
his canadian citizenship despite
spending so much of his time in the
united states he said i sometimes wonder
i've even regretted not having american
citizenship especially at election times
though reeves clarified that he isn't an
activist he does have a strong belief
that elections are important he said
ideally i would take out dual
nationality dual citizenship might be
reeves preference but with over 100
acting roles in under 40 years he's
hardly had the time to enjoy his
canadian citizenship much less seek out
another countries
when a famous actor pivots into writing
a book or a series of poems the results
are usually mixed at best keanu reeves
used the stereotype to his advantage
with his first poetry book ode to
happiness which was published in 2011.
each page contains a single line from
reeves paired with an illustration from
his girlfriend artist alexandra grant
grant told the bbc that ode to happiness
began its life as a joke she said our
friends sat at keanu's house one night
listening to wonderfully sad
self-pitying songs and keanu and the
spirits of poking fun at them began to
write a poem the book begins with the
line i draw a hot sorrow bath in my
despair rooms it then continues on in
that self-serious vein for the duration
reeves is the first to acknowledge that
the overwrought style of the poem isn't
meant to be taken seriously reeves told
bbc it's only personal in the sense of
looking out and regarding my sense of
humor i don't usually take baths in my
despair room with a misery candle
burning the collaboration was so
successful that it led to a second book
in 2016. shadows once again pairs poetry
with art but this time the coupling
isn't so humorous reeves told the
guardian that the book was an attempt to
quote contextualize the grief that he's
faced in his life he hoped that by
writing about the grief he could quote
even be inspired by it to even find a
certain pleasure in it
as it turns out poetry just wasn't
enough to satisfy reeves seemingly
bottomless artistic drive in the fall of
2017 he sat down with boom studios to
talk about a character and story idea
that had been lingering in his mind for
ages the meeting was the most
keanu-esque pitch imaginable he acted
out various scenes from the story which
follows an immortal hyper-violent man
constantly engaged in combat and showed
off his decades of fighting knowledge
reeve said it went comic book i went
yeah why not and with that berserker was
born reeves paired up with veteran comic
writer matt kind the mind behind mind
management to bring his story to
fruition the comic features an 80 000
year old man who in keanu's words could
punch people's chests and their backs
and rip people's arms off to life the
story was planned as a 12 issue
mini-series and boom launched a
kickstarter campaign to gauge interest
in the story the studio ended up with
1.5 million dollars in pre-orders the
wildly successful comic is already being
considered for a film adaptation and
reeves has stated that he would love to
play the role the project still needs to
find its perfect director but it likely
won't be long before berserker hits the
big screen
though it wasn't his first time fighting
his way through scenes and set pieces
keanu reeves became known as an action
movie star after the matrix i know kung
fu
show me the film came out more than 20
years ago but as he's gotten older
reeves has continually upped the ante
the john wick films directed by reeves
matrix stunt double chad stahelski are
filled with the type of visceral action
that usually relies on camera tricks and
highly trained martial artists however
reeves famously prefers to handle the
material himself he told sunday today i
do all of the action i'm 90 of what's
happening there he says that doing
action scenes in his 50s is more about
recovery than when he was younger but if
anything he's gotten better with time
reeves doesn't constrain his action
prowess to a single franchise either he
shot some pretty incredible stunts for
his return to the matrix and the matrix
resurrections reeves told stephen
colbert on the late show that he and
carrie anne moss jumped off a 46-story
building 19 to 20 times to nail down the
perfect shot when asked why he didn't
use cgi for the job reeves said because
it's lana wachowski and it's the matrix
and you need natural light and you want
to do it real that's a dedication of
someone who shaved their legs for a
commercial growing stronger with each
new opportunity
after all the time that keanu reeves has
spent in front of the camera it seems
only appropriate that he's gotten an
opportunity to sit in the director's
chair 2013's man of tai chi stars tiger
hoo chin as a young martial artist who
gets in too deep in an underground
fighting ring reeves not only directed
the film but also stretched his acting
range by starring as the film's main
antagonist the film wasn't nearly as
groundbreaking as previous reeves
outings but the critical consensus on
rotten tomatoes calls it an agreeably
old-fashioned picture for martial arts
fans and a solid debut for first-time
director keanu reeves reeves hasn't
directed a second film but that doesn't
mean he won't beserker writer matt kinn
does thrown reeves name into the hat for
directing the comic's film adaptation
telling the washington post there's no
one better to pull it off than him
keanu reeves has acted in more movies
than most people even aspire to but
don't let that trick you into thinking
that he's going to disappear from the
big screen anytime soon reeves told the
guardian around the time i hit 40 there
was this idea of creating more from my
artistic loins he said that he often
thinks about life like it's a reel of
tape when you're young you have a big
old reel of that tape left right and so
it appears to revolve slowly then time
passes and there's less and less tape
left on the reel it spins faster it
spins faster these days reeves is trying
to move just as fast as a spinning tape
he's revisiting old franchises like the
matrix and bill and ted while continuing
to push forward on more recent hits
notably there are currently two john
wick sequels in production at the same
time he's releasing poetry showing up in
video games and spending time with the
people closest to him he said work
doesn't slow time down if anything it
speeds everything up luckily for us
reeves still has plenty of tape left on
his reel
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]